we've seen you on the show on gear with
Rose doing a lot of medical work we met
you on the battlefield helping men out
there are we gonna get to see more of
your medical skills on the show do you
know what yes which is good
yeah mother's so there's in Game of
Thrones we're continuing on with the
wars and there's always people to heal
and in dates um I live in a hospital
with Ben Chaplin which is quite nice
no complaints there good not bad Richard
Martin and van Chaplin how do they
compare do you know what I've been like
the luckiest little fool in like my life
just wonderful on screen husbands and
boyfriends they're all so thick it's
kind of hard to choose it serves a
purpose I think I don't know which one
I'd marry though how important is your
weather is your marriage to rock did it
be for the rest of season 3
really important but it's always been
important sort of like the one
relationship that's about love and you
can get behind
there's not like agendas
it's just pure love here's a beautiful
relationship in the show of course it's
very different than something obviously
in the books isn't it how interesting is
after you developing something new on
screen and and also Game of Thrones is
such a tough show to survivin just to
lease I have what it takes
well I don't know is the answer to that
and
I think I think she's kind of too too
nice for the world that horrible world
of getting the crown and but yeah it's
very different from the books which is
nice because I think though the romance
is sort of better can we look forward to
seeing you next season please so yes
that would be telling
you say yes and you look forward to him
now if you do come back all right now
where would you like your story to go
do you know what Iceland and Croatia
look amazing I really like bumpers I'd
like to stay where I am what do you
enjoy about being a Belvoir whiskey nice
speedball
it's amazing that countryside and stuff
is just really fun to be there it's just
so lovely now there's been some amazing
deaths on Game of Thrones have it
they're incredible
if you have to die on the show how would
you like to go of natural causes sitting
on a throne with Richard Madden in my
arms in an embrace
good long kiss maybe yeah yeah like a
lingering death kiss who's been the best
death in the show for you they're very
inventive aren't they
Sean Dean like no one saw that coming
everyone I was like I thought that that
did not just happen
that was shocking now I know you've
obviously Robin your relationships very
important to show you've had some very
living scenes how you by playing kind of
intimate scenes when there's obviously a
huge crew there Arthur it's so much fun
I mean like you know there's those
horses for courses I love getting my
kiss off personally so I'm kind of cool
with it but I think it's really
important in Game of Thrones they always
have such a like and safe
and then everyone's really professional
I think everyone's so used to it as well
that nobody's like surprised or shocked
or anything that just makes you feel
really comfortable and Richard's been
amazing so I think it's just all really
fun like sex should be I like it
definitely I'm working with Michelle
Fairley how's that been as well the
woman I am so in love with her I think
she is not only a spectacular actress
with such a fun and generous and feeling
human beings Oh clever I've learned so
much from her just being round her and
huge easy is going to prevail do you
think we can see how start on the throne
we love those they're so nice how star
of all the way I have to say how star
ball the way I like it
team loyalty Oh team loyalty team world
Oh finally a message so the fans are
watching it
well there's going to be a lot of big
weddings this year but keep on watching
Game of Thrones
you